et pour faire table rase mesdames et
messieurs cela montre l'essence même de
la crise de confiance politique
européenne si les acteurs politiques
européens ne respectent pas les règles
et les décisions qu'ils se sont fixé eux
mêmes comment voulez-vous qu'il
convainque autrui de leur détermination
à régler cette crise ensemble
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs une crise de confiance est une
crise politique la bonne chose dans
cette affaire c'est que dans la en
démocratie n'y a pas de problèmes
politiques pour lesquels on ne peut pas
trouver une solution politique
voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui je voudrais
discuter avec où les questions
fondamentales politiques
où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui vers quoi
souhaitant nous aller et je veux plus
tôt pour parler de vision politique qui
doit inspirer nos décisions politiques
de demain
bien sûr je ne vais pas faire une liste
de décisions individuelles j'ai envoyé
lettre au président du parlement
européen qui énonce les priorités
immédiates de la commission nous en
discuterons avec vous avant d'adopter le
programme de la commission en automne le
message d'aujourd'hui est tant qu'athée
sans celui-ci
l'europe a besoin d'une nouvelle
direction d'une nouvelle orientation et
c'est direction ne peut pas reposer sur
des idées anciennes
l'europe a besoin de revoir sa vision
des choses lorsqu'on parle de crise nous
en parlons tous les jours avant nous
tirer toutes les conséquences pour nos
actions futures
lorsque nous parlons de mondialisation
et nous parlons tous beaucoup de
mondialisation s'en gargarise même est
ce que on a vu quel est l impact sur
chaque état membre de cette
mondialisation
le point de départ d'une nouvelle
réflexion sur l'europe c'est de tirer
toutes les conclusions de ces défis que
nous devons relever et qui changent de
manière fondamentale le monde dans
lequel nous vivons
le pan départ c'est de cesser de
répondre aux questions de l'avenir en
utilisant les réponses du passé depuis
le début de cette crise nous avons vu à
maintes reprises que ces marches et
interconnecté sont beaucoup plus rapides
et sont donc plus puissant que des
systèmes politiques nationaux fragmenté
ce qui
et érode la confiance des citoyens dans
la décision et c'est en fait tout ce qui
alimente le populisme l'extrémisme en
europe et ailleurs
le fait est que dans ce monde
interconnecté les états membres de
l'union européenne seuls ne sont plus en
mesure ne sont plus capables de régler
les choses diriger le cap de leur pays
mais en même temps ces pays ne se sont
pas dotés du mois l'union ne s'est pas
doté notre union ne s'est pas dotée des
instruments nécessaires pour faire face
à cette nouvelle réalité
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une phase
transitoire
nous sommes à un moment décisif et ce
moment appel des décisions et surtout un
leadership
il est vrai que la mondialisation exige
davantage d'unité européenne davantage
d'unité veut dire davantage
d'intégration davantage d'intégration
veut dire plus de démocratie démocratie
européenne j'entends en europe
ça veut dire que avant toute chose nous
devons accepter le fait que nous sommes
tous dans le même bateau reconnaître
également ce caractère commun de ses
intérêts ça veut dire aussi tenir compte
de cette interdépendance qui unit nos
destinées ça veut dire aussi un
véritable sens de responsabilité comme
une manifestation de solidarité lorsque
vous êtes dans un bateau en pleine
tempête
la loyauté et le minimum que l'on puisse
engager de exiger de votre équipage
c'est la seule manière de garder le
rythme des changements ce nec ainsi que
nous pourrons avoir l'efficacité
suffisante pour être un acteur mondial
c'est la seule manière de sauvegarder
nos valeurs parce qu'il s'agit là aussi
de valeurs qu'il faut préserver dans ce
monde en changement au xxème siècle un
pays de 10 de 15 millions d'individus
pouvait être un acteur mondial
au 21ème siècle même les pays européen
le plus grand qu le risque d'être
totalement des nains par rapport à des
pays comme la chine ou l'inde l'histoire
est en train d'accélérer
il a fallu cent vingt-cinq ans pour que
la grande bretagne double son pib par
capita 15 ans pour les états unis 50 ans
pour les états unis et 15 ans pour la
chine
si vous prenez nouveaux états membres
certains d'entre eux
cette transformation économique est tout
aussi impressionnante
l'europe a tous les atouts dans son jeu
pour réussir et davantage même encore
que les générations précédentes qui
connaissait le même type de défi
peut-être des défis plus importants
encore encore faut-il agir et mobilisé
l'ensemble de ses ressources
il est temps d'être de mettre en
adéquation les ambitions et les actions
de mettre un terme à ces réactions
atomisé et de bricoler il est temps de
tirer les enseignements de l'histoire et
d'écrire un nouvel avenir pour l'europe
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs ce que je vous présente
aujourd'hui et c'est un accord pour
l'europe pour projeter leur valeur notre
à neutre nos libertés dans un monde
nouveau
avec la nécessité de faire en sorte que
les économie sociale de marché soit
préservée mais que nous les réformes y
ont par ailleurs c'est un accord qui
permettra de stabiliser la croissance
économique me rétablir l'économie et
stabiliser l'euro un code de confiance
en quelque sorte entre l'ensemble de nos
pays entre les états membres entre les
institutions européennes entre les
partenaires sociaux et entre les
citoyens européens
cet accord pour l'europe doit être
décisif
nous devons être parfaitement clair sur
l'intégrité de l'union européenne et le
caractère irréversible de l'euro plus
les pays seront vus les pays vulnérables
ne doivent en aucun cas abandonner leur
volonté d'assumer leurs responsabilités
mais les pays les plus forts qu'eux
aussi doivent être parfaitement clair
sur la volonté à rester ensemble a
témoigné de ce sens de la solidarité
et nous devons parfaitement être clair
sur notre détermination à réformer à
réformer ensemble l'idée que nous
puissions croître sans réforme ou que
nous puissions être prospère sol est
fausse reconnaissons que nous sommes
dans le même bateau et que nous devons
donc trouver des solutions communes
il faut que l'on réalise une union
économique en profondeur fondée sur une
union politique mais commençant par
l'économie européenne tout d'abord nous
avons besoin de croissance avant tout
une croissance durable la croissance
c'est en fait ce qui irrigue le modèle
européen ça permet de créer des emplois
et de préserver notre niveau de vie
mais cette croissance n'est possible
qu'à condition d'être plus compétitif au
plan national ça veut dire faire des
réformes structurelles qui ont été
reportées depuis maintenant des années
faut réformer l'administration publique
éviter les gaspillages s'attaquer aux
privilèges réformer le marché avoir un
davantage de souplesse à voir la
durabilité également pour le service de
protection sociale au niveau revient
nous devons être plus décisif faire
tomber les barrières qu'elles soient
physiques économiques ou numérique 12
devant parachever le marché unique
réduire notre dépense notre dépendance
énergétique et trouver de nouvelles
formes d'énergie il faut être beaucoup
plus compétitifs en matière de numérique
de télécommunications faut promouvoir
l'innovation et dure les prix pour les
consommateurs et pour les entreprises la
commission présentera un acte marché
unique numéro deux pour que ce marché
unique puisse davantage prospérer la
commission a l'intention d'être ferme
intransigeante même pour défendre la
compétitivité et les règles en matière
des changes si on s'en remettait aux
états membres je peux vous garantir
qu'il ne résistera pas à la pression des
grandes entreprises ou de grands
pouvoirs extérieurs de grandes
puissances extérieures il nous faut
aussi créer un marché de l'emploi
européen
faire en sorte que les gens puissent
travailler ailleurs aussi facilement
qu'ils peuvent le faire chez eux
et puis la croissance verte est
importante il faut être plus efficace en
matière de gestion d'utilisation des
ressources et puis surtout se montrer
plus ambitieux en matière d'éducation de
recherche d'innovation et de sciences
l'europe est un leader en matière
d'aéronautique de voitures de produits
pharmaceutiques d'algérie avec des parts
de marché de près d'un tiers parfois la
productivité industrielle a augmenté de
35%
ces quelques décennies malgré la la le
ralentissement un grand nombre d'emplois
dépendent de l'industrie de chaque année
des start up créée plus de quatre
millions d'emplois en europe et nous
devons capitaliser sur ces données pour
investir dans une nouvelle politique
industrielle et créer un environnement
qui permettent le déploiement de
l'esprit d'entreprise et qui aide les
pme et donc les décisions ne doivent
être prises beaucoup plus simple il faut
que ces nous soyons plus plus
intéressant pour les investisseurs une
meilleure fiscalité sera profitable pour
tout le monde et puis une politique
commerciale doit être lancée en ouvrant
en défrichant de nouveaux marchés voilà
le potentiel que tout cas l'europe c'est
une mine qui n'est pas encore totalement
exploité et il faut également reprendre
le traité en matière de croissance a
levé par le conseil et puis on pourrait
aller plus loin tout en étant réaliste
grâce à un budget pour l'investissement
pour la croissance et la réforme
soyons parfaitement clair là dessus le
budget de l'union européenne est
l'instrument qui doit servir pour les
investissements et pour la croissance
européenne la commission ainsi que ce
parlement la commission et ce parlement
toutes les forces pro européenne doivent
se fédéraliser doit se mutualiser
puisque la plupart de ces pays qui sont
pour cette europe doivent défendre le
cadre
financier pluriannuel d'ici 2020 nous
avons proposé également un système de
ressources propres et cela permettra
aussi de relancer l'économie de ces pays
de leur région de leurs chercheurs leurs
étudiants leurs jeunes qui je recherche
d emploi et les pme en profiteront c'est
un budget en faveur de la croissance est
un budget en faveur de la cohésion
économique sociale et territoriale entre
les états membres et même dans les états
membres eux mêmes c'est un budget qui
permettra de parachever le marché
intérieur en comblant défausser sur le
plan de l'énergie delà des transports et
des télécoms grâce à connecting europe
c'est un budget en faveur de
l'agriculture une agriculture qui puisse
assurer la sécurité alimentaire
avec le développement rural durable
c'est un budget qui permettra d'avoir
également une europe en matière de
recherche grâce à horizon 2020 nous
avons besoin justement de cette
composante européenne pour la recherche
alors maintenant notre crédibilité est
en jeu pour la plupart de nos états
membres
je tiens à voir si les mêmes états
membres qui se gargarisent sur la
nécessité d'investir pour la croissance
et le développement voteront en faveur
de ce budget pour la croissance en
europe j'attends de voir quelle sera
leur réaction
ce budget est un budget qui est un
instrument pour l'europe 20
cette stratégie de croissance dont nous
avons besoin plus encore que par le
passé l'europe 20 20 et la manière de
moderniser surtout de préserver
l'économie sociale de marché européenne
mesdames et messieurs notre agenda de
réformes appelle un effort considérable
et ça ne marchera qu'à condition que ce
soit à la fois juste et équitable
l'inégalité n'est tout simplement pas
acceptables dans certaines régions nous
voyons vraiment des situations d'urgence
sociale
l'appauvrissement
le chômage notamment qui touchent les
jeunes voilà pourquoi nous devons
renforcer cette cohésion sociale c'est
l'avenir qui permettra de distinguer le
modèle européen d'autres modèles
alternatifs certains nous disent qu'en
raison de la crise le modèle social
européen est mort je ne suis pas
d'accord avec cela
il est vrai qu'il faut réformer nos
économies moderniser notre système de
protection sociale c'est vrai mais un
système de protection sociale qui aide
ceux qui sont dans le besoin n'est pas
un obstacle à la prospérité
c'est bien au contraire un élément
indispensable pour relancer cette
prospérité et ce soit précisément les
pays qui ont des systèmes de protection
sociaux les plus efficaces et qui ont
les systèmes de partenariats sociaux les
plus efficaces qui réussissent et qui
sont les modèles économiques les plus
compétitifs sur le plan mondial l'équité
la justice
ça veut dire aider les jeunes leur
donner une chance nous faisons déjà
énormément de choses pour eux avant la
fin de l'année la commission va utiliser
des mesures qui permettront de mettre en
place un système de gary t de garantie
pour les jeunes pour permettre une
meilleure formation professionnelle
juste assez égalité veut dire aussi
créer des systèmes fiscaux plus juste
arrêter la fraude fiscale l'évasion
fiscale ça pourrait mettre permettre de
verser des milliards dans le budget
européen
voilà pourquoi la commission voilà
pourquoi la commission se battra pour un
accord sur la directive économies
fiscales et aura des mandats pour
permettre de négocier des accords
fiscaux avec des pays tiers et ce sera
une source de recettes fiscales
supplémentaires et la commission se
battra pour
une système de transactions financières
qui soit efficace qui permettra au
secteur financier de verser également de
l'argent et non pas simplement l'
inverse
il est clair aujourd'hui qu'un accord ne
peut se faire que par une coopération
renforcée
la coop la commission fera de son mieux
pour que les choses puissent bouger
rapidement et de manière efficace avec
les états membres qui sont désireux de
le faire parce qu'il s'agit d' équité il
s'agit de justice et c'est une condition
sinequanone pour que les réformes
économiques puisse se faire et qu'elle
soit acceptable sur le plan social et
sur le plan politique les quitter et
tout ça pour moi une question de justice
de justice sociale
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs face à cette crise des
décisions importantes ont été prises
dans l'union européenne des réformes et
mesures de consolidation sont
aujourd'hui mises en oeuvre des systèmes
sont mises en place et nous avons
toujours montré que nous étions
favorables à l'euro que nous voulons le
défendre bec et ongles la commission sec
dans les états membres qui mettent en
place ces réformes il y a aujourd'hui la
misère des difficultés il ya parfois des
systèmes d'adaptation particulièrement
douloureux mais ce n'est que grâce à ces
réformes que nous pourrons voir à
l'avenir plus rose ces réformes auraient
dû être fait depuis très longtemps
revenir au statu quo est impossible la
commission continue de faire de son
mieux pour aider les états membres à
relancer la croissance et l'emploi
grâce aux reprogramme âge des fonds
structurels je vais dire deux mots
d'ailleurs à propos de la grèce puisque
je pense que nous avons la possibilité
cet automne d'en arriver à la croisée
des chemins si la grèce fait table rase
de tous les doutes concernant sa volonté
de réformer mais si les autres pays
également montre la détermination
nécessaire pour aider la grèce
nous y arriverons à ce moment là si la
grèce respecte ses engagements elle
pourra rester membre de cette famille
européenne
assurer la sécurité de la zone euro est
aussi un défi essentiel c'est la
responsabilité conjointe des états
membres et des institutions de l'union
européenne la banque centrale européenne
ne peut pas et ne financera pas
d'ailleurs les gouvernements mais
lorsque les politiques que lorsque les
canaux monétaire ne fonctionne pas la
commission estime que c'est dans le
cadre de la bc dans le mandat de la bce
de prendre les mesures nécessaires sur
les marchés secondaires par exemple pour
intervenir sur la dette souveraine et
d'ailleurs la bce a le droit mais
surtout le devoir de rétablir
l'intégrité de toute politique monétaire
bien sûr c'est la bce qui est une
institution indépendante c'est à elle de
déterminer quelles sont les mesures à
prendre et dans quelles conditions
mais tous les acteurs et j'entends par
là absolument tous les acteurs devraient
respecter l'indépendance de la bce
mesdames et messieurs j'ai longuement
parlé de mesures économiques qui devront
être mises en oeuvre de manière urgente
elles sont indispensables mais ça ne
suffira pas nous devons aller plus loin
nous devons achever l'union économique
et monétaire
nous devons créer une union bancaire une
union budgétaire et les institutions et
les mécanismes y afférents aujourd'hui
la commission présente des propositions
législatives pour un mécanisme de
supervision unique pour la zone euro et
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui va nous
amener vers l'union bancaire cette crise
a démontré que lorsque les banques
deviennent transnationales et règle la
surveillance
elle reste nationale et lorsque les
choses ont dysfonctionné ce sont les
contribuables qui ont été priés de de
passer à la caisse
deux bleus les dispositions pour les
banques par deux dispositions mais la
coordination les puces suffisante il
faut des décisions de supervision
commune dans la zone euro en particulier
le mécanisme de supervision unique
proposée aujourd'hui permettra une
architecture renforcé avec la banque
centrale européenne qui aura un rôle
beaucoup plus important et les autorités
bancaires permettront ainsi de rétablir
la confiance en matière de supervision
cette supervision s'appliquera à toutes
les banques européennes cette
supervision doit pouvoir fouiller
partout parce que les risques
systématiques se cache un peu partout et
pas simplement dans les banques
importantes sur le plan systémique
le tout dans un système qui s'engage qui
permet d'engager bien sûr les
superviseurs nationaux ce paquet prévoit
de pacte l'un pour la bce et l'autre
pour le berre et les deux vont de pair
le parlement aura un rôle important à
jouer au moment de l'adoption de ces
nouveaux mécanismes et ensuite dans la
supervision démocratique de
l'application c'est un pas vers la
l'union bancaire que je vous ai proposé
au mois de juin
mettre en place cette supervision
européenne est une priorité essentielle
aujourd'hui puisque c'est la condition
sine qua none pour une meilleure gestion
la crise bancaire et
en particulier parallèle la commission
continue de travailler sur la réforme du
secteur bancaire de manière à ce que ce
dernier joue son rôle et financent
l'économie réelle et donc améliorer
notamment le financement à long terme
pour les pme des règles en matière de
référence et d'un disque manière à ce
que nous ne voyons pas une fois encore
manipuler les taux d'intérêts bancaires
qui toucheront les entreprises elles
étaient en tort d'hypothèque
ça veut dire une législation pour faire
en sorte que les banques permettent de
faire des prêts à de bonnes conditions
consommateur et qu'on puisse également
éviter les risques inhérents dans les
activités bancaires et le rôle de ce
parlement dont tout cela est essentiel
la commission tente de travailler en
étroite collaboration avec le parlement
bien entendu et puis s'ajoute à cela un
deuxième élément pour cette union
économique
c'est cette volonté d'aller vers une
union budgétaire
les arguments sont claires les décisions
économiques d'un état membre ont un
impact sur son voisin et donc il nous
faut une coordination politique de
politique économique plus forte une
faute un cadre pour les décisions
fondamentales de chaque pays pour éviter
des déséquilibres
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été faites
par le six pack en particulier et par
les recommandations spécifiques pour les
pays
des mesures supplémentaires sont
nécessaires pour mettre en place les
conditions avec des encouragements
spécifique faire en sorte que l'union
économique et monétaire soit enfin
rendue durable et puis les résultats
pour qu'il soit durable doivent mettre
en place une gouvernance avec une
capacité budgétaire crédible nous
n'avons pas besoin de séparer et les
institutions surtout de créer de
nouvelles institutions pour ça c'est
même l'inversé qui est vrai pour que ce
système marche
la meilleure façon c'est de travailler
grâce au mécanisme grâce aux
institutions existantes
la commission qui a une qui est une
autorité indépendante qui est contrôlé
par le parlement européen qui la
représentation parlementaire suffisent
et c'est dans ce cadre là que au fil du
temps des mesures permettant une
mutualisation de la tête des garanties
pourront se mettre en place petit à
petit la réforme économique
couplé à une union économique et
monétaire sont les deux moteurs qui
doivent nous permettre de relancer
machine européenne la commission
présentera un document pour une union
économique et monétaire en profondeur
avant l'automne
et ce brouillon sera présenté devant le
parlement européen puisque tout ça doit
être discuté bien sûr avec les
représentants des populations
européennes en même temps lors du
conseil de décembre
nous allons préparer un texte que le
président la banque centrale européenne
que la commission et que le conseil
devront présenter ce document présentera
les objectifs et des objectifs surtout
législatif qui permettront de mettre en
oeuvre cette coordination politique la
capacité budgétaire et les systèmes
d'amortissement de la tête comme c'est
le cas de cet endettement
ça permettra aussi de voir quels sont
les changements nécessaires pour le
traité puisque certains changements
appelle les changements du traité nous
présenterons donc un document sur ce
qu'il faudra faire non pas au cours des
prochaines semaines des prochains mois
mais ce qu'il conviendra de faire au
cours des prochaines années
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs enfin cette crédibilité la
durabilité de l'union économique et
monétaire
cette crédibilité de l'euro dépendront
des institutions et de la construction
politique qui la sous tend voilà
pourquoi l'union économique et monétaire
pose la question d'une union politique
cela démocraties européennes bien sûr
qu'il doit les reggae si nous voulons
que l'union économique et monétaire
fonctionne nous devons également
combiner l'ambition est une des mesures
concrètes de mesures concrètes doivent
être prises maintenant mais avec l'union
politique comme étant l'horizon
politique j'aimerais que les questions
européennes puisse être discuté dans un
espace européen avec une un éclairage
européen on ne peut pas régler les
problèmes européens avec des solutions
au national
ce débat doit intervenir dans toutes nos
sociétés auprès de l'opinion publique
et aujourd'hui je lance un appel un
appel vibrant au aux hommes et aux
femmes de culture participer à ce débat
sur l'avenir de l'europe nous avons
besoin de vos et je lance également cet
appel à vous mesdames et messieurs voilà
où se déroule la démocratie européenne
nous devons renforcer le rôle du
parlement européen au niveau européen et
nous devons assurer une complémentarité
entre le parlement européen et les
parlements nationaux
ça ne peut pas se faire sans renforcer
les partis politiques européens et très
souvent il ya eu un manque de connexions
entre les partis politiques dans les
capitales et les partis politiques ici
au parlement européen à strasbourg
voilà pourquoi nous devons reconnaître
que ce débat politique trop souvent est
présenté comme s'il s'agissait de partis
nationaux même dans les élections
européennes on ne voit pas les noms des
partis politiques européens au moment de
mettre notre bulletin dans le scrutin on
voit simplement débat entre partis
politiques nationaux et donc il faut un
statut pour les partis politiques
européens
la commission a adopté aujourd'hui une
proposition qui va dans ce sens et j'ai
grand plaisir de vous l'annoncer
il faut également renforcer ce débat
paneuropéen et on pourrait les partis
politiques pour repère pourrait
présenter leurs candidats aux postes de
la commission européenne pour les
élections 2014
et on peut le faire sans changer le
traité et ce sera me semble-t-il un pas
décisif pour permettre un choix européen
qu'offrent ces élections ce sera quelque
chose d'encore plus manifeste je lance
donc un appel aux partis politiques de
s'engager dans cette voie et d'
européaniser en quelque sorte ces
élections européennes davantage encore
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs une union politique économique
européenne et fait qu'il faut se
concentrer sur les questions importantes
et il faut traiter ces affaires au
niveau européen maintenant soyons
complètement honnête tout ne peut pas
être fait au même moment tous les pas
prioritaire nous devons hiérarchiser ses
priorités
et là une forme d'autocritique est tout
à fait indispensable une véritable
intégration c'est voir une nouvelle
vision sur le niveau d'action le plus
approprié la subsidiarité est un concept
démocratique très important qui doit
être pratiquée sur le terrain cette
union politique veut dire aussi que nous
devons renforcer les fondations sur
lesquelles repose notre union
le respect de ses valeurs fondamentales
l'état de droit la démocratie en sont
les piliers
ces derniers mois nous avons vu des
menaces contre le tissu économique et
démocratique dans certains états membres
repère le parlement européen et la
commission ont été les premiers à tirer
la sonnette d'alarmé a joué un rôle
décisif pour faire en sorte que ces
évolutions soit eux ont cadré soit
étouffée mais dans ce genre de situation
nous avons vu que nos dispositions
institutionnelles honte des limites il
faut un meilleur batterie d'instruments
et pas simplement d un des alternatives
entre la persuasion politique le sortent
pas oies et l'article 7 qui est en fait
la bombe atomique d'une certaine manière
notre engagement en faveur de l'état de
droit nous amène à penser qu'il faut
également un procureur européen comme le
prévoit d'ailleurs les traités et c'est
une proposition que nous ferons sous peu
mesdames et messieurs monsieur le
président une union politique veut dire
aussi jouer notre rôle global partagé la
souveraineté ça veut dire être plus
souverain également dans un monde
mondialisé
la taille est très importante
aujourd'hui et ce sont les valeurs qui
font la différence voilà pourquoi le
message européen doit être un message de
liberté de démocratie d'état de droit de
solidarité
bref les valeurs qui sous-tendent de
l'union européenne
plus que par le passé encore les
citoyens ont besoin d'un nouvel ordre
monde
allez nous avons besoin d'une europe qui
soit influentes pour l'europe bien sûr
mais aussi pour le restant du monde il
est important que l'euro soit influentes
et qu'elle respecte ses valeurs qu'elle
les défendent la valeur de l'homme les
droits de l'homme ne sont pas quelque
chose d'optionnel c'est au contrat
quelque chose qui doit être universel la
situation épouvantable en syrie montrent
que nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre
le luxe d'être des spectateurs une
nouvelle syrie démocratique doivent
apparaître
nous avons la responsabilité conjointe
de faire advenir 7 syrie démocratique et
ce dans un monde dans un ordre mondial
où cette coopération doit se façonner
nous avons besoin d'une union européenne
qui soit qui assure son leadership sur
le plan de l'assistance humanitaire en
particulier avec des économies ouvertes
où nous luttons contre le programme la
protection contre un protectionnisme
nous avons le monde a besoin d'une
europe qui puisse déployer des missions
militaires pour tenter de stabiliser des
cris dans des les des situations dans
des crises et puis nous devons avoir des
capacités européennes
et puis également prévoir également une
défense commune
nous devons renforcer notre politique de
sécurité commune et avoir une approche
commune en matière de défense
ensemble nous avons le pouvoir et
surtout la force pour faire en sorte que
l'europe que le monde soit un endroit
qui respecte la démocratie les valeurs
de l'homme mesdames et messieurs une
union économique et monétaire
une union politique avec une politique
de défense commune veut dire et une
fille née que l'union européenne
d'aujourd'hui doivent évoluer
et n'ayons pas peur des mots nous aurons
besoin d'aller vers une fédération
d'états nations c'est ce dont nous avons
besoin
voilà quelle doit être notre horizon
politique
voilà ce qui doit nous guider nous
orienter dans les prochaines années
aujourd'hui j'appelle à cette fédération
des états nations et non pas un super
état une fédération démocratique d'état
nation qui puisse régler les problèmes
qui nous sont communs en partageant la
souveraineté de manière à ce que chaque
pays et que chaque citoyen soit mieux
adapté soit mieux équipés pour maîtriser
sa destinée il s'agit d'une union avec
les états membres et non pas d'une union
contre les états membres à l'ère de la
mondialisation cette souveraineté
mutualiser vos d'avant veut dire
davantage le pouvoir et non pas moins de
pouvoir et je le dis à dessein une
fédération d'états nations parce que je
pense que dans cette période troublée
cette période d'incertitude
ce serait commettre une erreur que de
laisser la défense des nations aux
nationalistes et aux populistes j'ai foi
dans une europe où les gens soient fiers
de leur pays
mais soit aussi fier d'être européen et
soient fiers de défendre les valeurs
européennes
le fait de créer cette fédération des
états nations
appellera à long terme un nouveau traité
et je le dis pas à la légère
nous sommes tous conscients du de la
difficulté qu'il ya à ces changements
qu'ils aient à faire ces changements de
traité tout ça doit être bien préparé il
ne faut pas pour autant que nous
accueillons de retard nous devons faire
ce qui doit être fait maintenant une
union économique et monétaire renforcer
peut commencer dans le cadre des traités
actuels mais ne peut être achevé qu'avec
des changements dans les traités
donc commençons dès maintenant mais
fixons nous cet espace de dorison et ne
l'oublions pas de notre chance dans
notre champ de vision
nous devons commencer ces changement des
traités identifier les politiques dont
nous avons besoin identifié les
instruments dont nous avons besoin
ensuite pour nous voir quels sont les
changements effectués
et puis ensuite il doit y avoir un débat
en europe toute entière
un débat avant qu'ait lieu une
convention est une cg un débat qui est
une véritable dimension européenne
l'époque de du consensus implicite de la
part des citoyens et appartient au passé
l'europe ne peut pas être technocratique
ou diplomatique elle doit être surtout
démocratique et le rôle du parlement
européen dans cette affaire est tout à
fait essentiel voilà pourquoi les
élections européennes en 2014 peuvent
être peuvent jouer un rôle décisif avant
les prochaines élections parlementaires
en 2014
la commission se propose de présenter
une esquisse pour représenter l'avenir
de l'union européenne et nous
présenterons des idées explicite pour
des changements de traité à temps pour
qu'ait lieu un débat réellement robert
nous fixerons des objectifs la manière
dont les institutions pourront être plus
ouverte plus démocratique
les instruments pour la rendre plus
efficace et également d'en faire un
modèle pour les populations européennes
je crois que nous avons besoin d'un réel
débat est en démocratie
la meilleure manière de débattre c'est
de préparer les élections et ensuite de
voir le verdict des urnes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs ça n'est pas simplement à un
débat pour la zone euro en l'état actuel
des choses soient parfaitement claires
en europe nous n'avons pas besoin de
murs qui nous divisent les uns les
autres qui nous séparent les uns des
autres
l'union européenne est plus forte
ensemble en préservant l'intégrité de
son marché unique et ses institutions
l'europe est beaucoup plus forte
personne ne sera contraint de nous
suivre personne ne sera contraint de
rester dehors non plus mais la visite de
la vita sera pas déterminée par l'acteur
le plus lent voilà pourquoi nous allons
faire des propositions sur la base des
institutions existantes sur la méthode
communautaire
il n'ya une seule union européenne une
commission européenne un seul parlement
européen soyons clairs là-dessus
davantage de démocratie et davantage de
transparence et de responsabilité ne
peut pas être le fait d'une
prolifération d'institutions qui
rendrait l'union européenne totalement
illisible ou incohérentes et totalement
entravé dans ses actions mesdames et
messieurs voilà les décisions qu'il
conviendra de prendre fil du temps voilà
pourquoi je pense que nous avons besoin
d'un débat avec les citoyens européens
pour frayer la voie du futur pour voir
aussi quelles seraient les conséquences
de cette fragmentation car ce qu'il
arrive parfois c'est que par certaines
conséquences il pourrait se produire
cette espèce de fragmentation dont nous
ne voulons pas mais aussi voir ce que
nous pourrions faire si nos leaders
évitait une espèce de provincialisme de
clochemerlesque nationale nous devons
utiliser ces fossés ces élections de
2014 pour ne pas permettre aux
populistes de fixer un agenda négatif
tous ceux qui sont européens doit se
lever doivent prendre des initiatives
dans ce débat car ce qui serait plus de
l'anchois encore que le scepticisme des
anti-européens c'est l'indifférence ou
le pessimisme des pro européens
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs pour résumer nous avons besoin
donc d'un accord pour racheter l'union
économique et monétaire
avec un engagement politique 7
ce cadencement est claire nous devons
commencer par tout faire pour stabiliser
l'europe à accélérer la croissance dans
l'union européenne dans sa globalité la
commission va présenter les propositions
nécessaires comme nous commençons le
faire aujourd'hui avec ce superviseur
unique pour créer cette union bancaire
ensuite qui soit en adéquation avec les
dispositions du traité
d'autre part nous allons vous présenter
un projet sur une union économique avec
les instruments politiques renforcer et
nous le ferons d'ici l'automne
nous vous présenterons d'autres
propositions dans le cadre du traité
actuel est là où n'est plus possible de
d'avancé dans le cadre du traité actuel
nous allons vous faire des propositions
concrètes pour lé changement des traités
nécessaires avant les prochaines
élections de 2014 avec notamment des
éléments permettant de renforcer la
démocratie et la responsabilité
voilà quelle est notre projet c'est un
projet qui se fait de manière graduelle
mais avec une ambition forte pour
l'avenir avec une fédération qui doit
être l'horizon européen
je suis certain que vous allez me dire
c'est trop ambitieux que ça n'est pas
réaliste mais je vous pose la question
suivante est il réaliste
de continuer sur notre lancée actuelle
est ce qu'il est réaliste d'accepter ce
que nous voyons aujourd'hui se produire
dans certains pays est il réaliste de
voir des contribuables payer la facture
des banques et ensuite être contraint de
rendre aux banques
les maisons parce qu'elles ne peuvent
plus le rembourser les hypothèques plus
de 40 50 % de nos jeunes aujourd'hui
sont au chômage
est-ce que c'est réaliste ça est il
réaliste de continuer de bricoler chacun
dans son coin de d'accumuler les erreurs
sans donner des réponses convaincantes
et il est réaliste de penser que nous
puissions rétablir la confiance auprès
des marchés alors que parfois nous
montrons que nous ne nous faisons pas
confiance les uns les autres pour moi
c'est cette réalité qui est irréaliste
tout simplement
c'est cette réalité cet état de fait qui
ne peut pas perdurer la manière réaliste
l'avancé c'est celle qui nous rend plus
forts plus unis
le réalisme c'est peut-être de mettre
notre ambition à la hauteur des défis
le réalisme c'est de dire à nos jeunes
qu'il y a des lueurs d'espoir à
condition que nous essaierions les rangs
et que en fait nous pencher en faveur de
l'espoir ne devrait y être honoré et
heureux d'être européen malgré nos
problèmes d'aujourd'hui
nos sociétés sont parmi les plus
humaines parmi les plus libres à travers
le monde nous n'avons pas à nous excuser
de notre économie sociale de marché de
nos valeurs de notre démocratie
pourquoi nous en excuser
avec des niveaux de cohésion sociaux
importants avec le respect des droits de
l'homme de la dignité humaine l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes avec le
respect pour notre environnement et bien
grand saut cela ces sociétés européennes
malgré ses difficultés ses sociétés
européennes sont parmi les sociétés les
plus décente dans l'histoire de
l'humanite m
et je crois que nous pouvons que quand
être fier dans nos pays mesdames et
messieurs
on ne va pas en prison parce que on
critique le gouvernement dans nos pays
les gens sont libres sont fiers de cette
liberté et les gens comprennent ce que
cela veut dire que de vivre dans un
environnement de liberté dans nos pays
notamment les plus récents on se
souvient fort bien de ce que voulait
dire le totalitarisme et la dictature
les générations précédentes ont surmonté
défi beaucoup plus important c'est un
autre génération de montrer que nous
sommes à la hauteur de la tâche
le mans est à présent revenu pour tous
les européens de laisser de côté les
habitudes et au contraire de s'engager
dans des voies dans des voies nouvelles
l'union européenne intégrée pour
garantir la paix aujourd'hui ça veut
dire faire de l'union européenne une
union qui soit à la hauteur des défis de
la mondialisation voilà pourquoi nous
avons besoin d'une nouvelle vision du
monde d accord européen voilà pourquoi
nous devons nous orienter aux valeurs
qui sont au coeur même de cette union
européenne
je pense que l'europe a une âme et cette
âme peut nous donner la détermination et
la volonté de faire ce que nous devons
faire compter sur la commission
européenne je compte sur vous parlement
européen car ensemble nos deux
institutions communautaires permettront
de façonner une europe plus forte une
union des citoyens pour aborder l'avenir
de l'europe mais aussi l'avenir du monde
merci de m'avoir écouté
vous venez d'écouté josé manuel barroso
le président de la commission européenne
qui s'exprimait au parlement européen de
strasbourg discours sur fond de crise
européenne alors que tombe aujourd'hui
la décision des juges allemands qui
doivent valider ou pas le mécanisme
européen de sauvetage on en reparle dans
nos éditions à venir sur les chaînes
parlementaires bonne journée à tous
les français appelés à faire des efforts
y at il une issue européenne et la crise
internationale la france et l écouter
laurent fabius ministre des affaires
étrangères est l'invité de questions
d'info cette semaine questions d'info en
partenariat avec l' afp le monde et
france info c'est ce soir à 19h30
comment savez comment ça va me lafforgue
victoire de la foncière super
je
les femmes ont continué à sa soeur
dessus ou on change pour de bon les
laboratoires étaient tout savoir sur les
programmes
voir ou revoir les émissions réagir aux
débats et participer au forum aller plus
loin au coeur de l'info politique et
parlementaire lcp am.fr ensemble pour
voir la politique en grand lcp assemblée
nationale en partenariat avec le crédit
social des fonctionnaires
l'alternative crédit assurance épargne
pour tous les agents des services
publics aux présentes des actifs musique
l'hymne de la semaine politique
bientôt quatre mois qu'il est président
et sa cote de popularité est en chute
libre
pour françois hollande l'été rose est
bel et bien terminée on se demandait ce
que françois hollande avait fait bon ses
vacances on a compris la préparer un
discours dont il ya un discours de
rentrée pour qu'on sache que françois
hollande est bien rentré au devoir c'est
de dire la vérité aux français nous
sommes devant une crise d'une gravité
exceptionnelle trois millions de
chômeurs une barre symbolique qui
inquiète la classe politique en premier
lieu jean marc ayrault
la situation est extrêmement
préoccupante est-ce que ça va augmenter
encore beaucoup
oui ça va encore augmenter ne
dramatisons pas pris non parce qu'ils se
bougent le dirigeant olivier se bougent
danse de saint-guy mais ça ça sympa à
longchamp hollande en terrain miné pour
le parisien aujourd'hui en france
hollande se côtoient il y a le feu le
premier conseil des ministres mercredi
dernier était d'ailleurs consacrée à
l'emploi avec une première mesure
annoncée les emplois d'avenir
cent mille emplois pour les jeunes sans
qualification quatre fois plus c'est
d'ici la fin du quinquennat
la seule réponse sur l'emploi c'est de
créer 150 mille emplois jeunes sur fonds
publics qui en réalité comme sous
martine aubry ne répondra absolument pas
au coeur du problème c'est les créations
d'emplois dans les entreprises devront
suivre les contrats de génération 500
mille contrats en cinq ans l'idée c'est
de vous le savez de couple et l'embauché
d'un jeune en cdi
en échange du maintien dans l'entreprise
d'un senior à chaque contrat signé et
bien l'entreprise va toucher une aide de
4000 euros par an en fait ces deux mille
euros pour le jeune embauché cette aide
elles durent trois ans et 2000 euros
pour le seigneur et le senior et cette
aide
enel va durer jusqu'à la retraite en
clair pas question de sacrifier le
social au détriment d'une politique de
rigueur
je ne veux pas être le premier ministre
d'un tournant de l'austérité parce que
la politique nous aurions engagé au
début du quinquennat
aucun échec les plans de licenciements
se multiplient peugeot doux air france
géraud la situation économique est
catastrophique qu'est ce que j'avais
prévu de faire pour un était sain une
lente aux réformes qui sont en cours
elles sont lentes à mettre en place mais
nous avons cinq ans pour y arriver soyez
patients et fait confiance au
gouvernement
vous verrez que j'avais déjà changé
d'avis faites vous plaisir
on peut y aller il faut essayer de viser
voilà en tout cas
en tout cas vous prenez n'importe quel
journal ou hebdomadaire cette semaine le
point on se réveille fini de rire
l'express les cocus de françois hollande
et cette semaine si sarkozy avait eu
raison
on vise une croissance revue à la baisse
par le cdo nous serions 0,1 pour cent
pour cette année alors que
l'organisation prévoyait 0 6% de hausse
pour 2013 ce serait moins bien que les 1
22 % qui sont visés on le rappelle par
le gouvernement sont ils si nul
évidemment vous avez vu le parallèle la
même couverture que celle du point en
2010 contre nicolas sarkozy alors en
termes de compétitivité nous perdons
trois places pour nous retrouver tout
simplement 21e position on sent
l'affolement la rentrée parlementaire un
seul exemple devait avoir lieu le 2
octobre
on nous dit non non c'est avancée au 10
septembre parce qu'on va faire plein de
choses
oui oui on se réunit deux jours et on
repart en vacances et on revient le 25
septembre
donc tout ça est complètement improvisé
on sent là seulement d'un gouvernement
qui est dépassé alors sur la dette
action ou vérité vérité la bête ne va
jamais arrêté de se creuser sur le
pouvoir d'achat action vérité vérité le
pouvoir d'achat va s'effondrer les
français sont mal vous avez vu le gîte
tout bon hein
une dernière je suis imbattable à ce jeu
bon alors plus personnel maintenant vous
n'avez pas un peu regrossi non je
choisis une action action réconcilier
ségolène royal et valérie trierweiler
vérité j'ai rempli 15 kilos en un mois
gevrey chambertin tout le monde mais
j'aurais chambertin c'est un chinois qui
l'a rachetée mais bien sûr quand vous
allez vous installer autour de gevrey
chambertin avec les troupes du mec
écoutez écoutez écoutez écoutez écoutez
moi je veux bien que vous juillet la
partition du fatalisme c'est ce que nous
dit d'ailleurs les gouvernements et
gouvernement ça fait 40 ans qu'on tombe
les indicateurs sont tous de plus en
plus mauvais donc pas tout le médium de
gevrey-chambertin mais c'est normal
non mais c'est normal dans l'économie
tels telle qu'elle est en même temps
évidemment ça fait un peut saigner m'ont
un peu c'est nier mon coeur vous avez
déjà eu des appels du pied
oui bien sûr ça a été de l'ump qu'il
soit de vous rejoindre à deux
personnalités pas pas au niveau de bien
sûr de militants et puis et puis de
cadres et même mêmes d'élus il faut
quand même elle est incorporée vous
savez très bien être nouvelle directrice
de cabinet qui fait une proche d'henri
guaino donc dans quoi celle d'un corps
dans quoi ben justement dans ces déçus
de l'ump qui pourraient vous rejoindre
il y à la marraine de votre fils
charlotte soulac a été nommé hier je
directrice de cabinet excusez moi cette
mesure n'a rien à faire dans cette
émission dénommée y est venu me chercher
c'est partout mais c'est que nous avons
reçues sera pas dans le communiqué il a
écrit que c'est ma marraine tient sa
maman sellama rien de mon fils
bon donc ça c'est une affaire privée on
assiste à l'explication de l'impuissance
et en même temps à une cacophonie
gouvernementale tout à fait stupéfiante
je crois que jean marc ayrault et non
seulement dépassé par la gravité de la
crise économique et sociale mais il est
aussi complètement dépassé par les
bisbilles et les crois qu'au sein de son
gouvernement
arnaud montebourg veut se défendre de
tout conflit d'intérêts il n'a rien à
voir avec la nomination de matthieu
pigasse chargé d'accompagner la création
de la future banque publique
d'investissement propriétaire de
l'hebdomadaire les inrockuptibles il y a
quelques semaines il a nommé audrey
pulvar la compagne d'arnaud montebourg à
la direction du magazine
c'est pas moi qui l'ait prise et
monsieur moscovici vous devriez lui
demander pourquoi il a choisi la banque
lazard vous savez d'autant que la banque
publique d'investissement je trouve que
ne peut pas être réalisée par des
banquiers parce que faire une banque qui
ressemblerait à d'autres banques c'est
vraiment parce qu'on cherche à faire
il est pas tendre avec vous là dessus je
fais pas preuve d'une grande solidarité
que je vais être moi très solidaire je
veux une école qui soit capable entre
tous les enfants de france de rassembler
autour d'un certain nombre de valeurs
que nous connaissions d'ailleurs un
c'est la liberté c'est l'égalité c'est
la justice et donc tout cela ça
s'apprend c'est les cours de morale
utilisé l'expression il s'agit et oui
c'est tout à fait bienvenu est normal
y'a pas besoin de rajouter des cours de
morale c'est uniquement une annonce
politicienne sur laquelle il espère
focaliser la tonte l'attention des
parents qui vont dire ah bah oui face
aux problèmes d'incivilité aux problèmes
de sécurité
on va remettre de la morale ça va tout
régler j'ai lu avec attention
l'interview de vincent peillon
je constate que mot pour mot ce sont les
propos d'une déclaration d'un appel du
25 juin 1940 du maréchal pétain alors
naturellement
j'y vois une maladresse fâcheuse ne
savais pas que monsieur chatel faisait
partie de ces belles âmes qui voit du
pétain ou 8 l'air partout faut arrêter
avec ça enfin il leur faut arrêter
vraiment avec ça les cen-sad quelques
associations subventionnées qu'ils le
font très bien
nous avons à restaurer la france c'est
un redressement intellectuelle et morale
que je vous convie voilà les maux dont
par luc chatel prononcé au lendemain de
la signature de l'armistice avec
l'allemagne une polémique politicienne
car sur le fond les deux hommes sont
d'accord sur la question de la morale à
l'école
luc chatel rappelle même qu'il en a été
l'un des initiateurs
quand je vois la réflexion de luc chatel
je me dis qu'il faudrait même instauré
une formation continue de morale laïque
et de respect lyon n'est pas pétain a
évidemment payé on se prend pour ferry
par contre jules il a un peu cette
tendance un peu étonnante à se prendre
un peu pour rien
un jour peut-être quand il aura fait
beaucoup de progrès il faut pas croire
ce qu on lit partout et surtout surtout
pas les fables de l'otan le premier
ministre a de l'autorité le premier
ministre corps de l'action de son
gouvernement et chacun ministre est au
travail
états unis un nouveau candidat à la
présidentielle décembre de son bus de
campagne à charlotte où se tient la
convention démocrate
c'est le premier candidat zombies sont
au programme l'égalité des chances pour
tous et surtout pour les zombies
injustement oublié pour démontrer son
dynamisme
il fera même un tour en tant que
passager dans une voiture de course sur
le circuit de la ville une blague bien
sûr mais qui caricaturent tous les
tickets et usages de la campagne
présidentielle
tous vous remercier christian le soutien
de françois ne m'a jamais fait défaut il
a été un ministre de l'industrie
extrêmement engagé un premier ministre
exemplaire christian c'est le maire de
la cinquième ville de france nous avons
toujours travaillé dans une confiance
absolue c'est un élu de terrain sur
lequel je compte beaucoup
je suis venu vous parler de la france je
suis venu parler de la france français
non par le sang reçu moi-même français
au sommet laisser mon qui m'a changé
parce que les épreuves de la vie m'ont
changé
et tant pis si ça fait pas plaisir à
saint germain des prés les tartuffes qui
habite boulevard saint germain et vous
vous reconnaissez pas monsieur guaino
dans ce que portent les autres ça va
être quoi votre singularité et bien si
je me reconnaissais je ne serai pas
candidat j'ai mûrement réfléchi j'ai
beaucoup j'ai beaucoup pensé à cette
question non je ne me reconnais pas que
deux candidats qui ont le droit de
présenter ce sera un des mythes
démocratie voilà si tu sais pas alors
c'est la faute de personne aujourd'hui
ce système